la colère
on a fait une gamme spéciale a bon goût
il ya des supporters du rc lens qui se
fout de ma gueule là bas mais
attendez-vous magnifique et supporters
du rc lens on les embauche à ça vous va
très bien vous allez on est visiblement
sur twitter j'ai deux thèmes le seul à
qui s'appelait un cabanon alors je vous
jure que ça va super bien
moi j'adore les aubergines j'adore la
moussaka ja dans le rapport à résoudre
il s'est déclaré que deux berlines
j'adore ça je vous le dis allez c'est
parti
sa maman chérie et contraindre à tulle
et bien sûr luc lemoine way ou puisque
julien courbet au moins non alors qu'est
ce que tu aimes personne puisque gilles
combet hmm hmm hmm mt par an ben hassine
quand même ouais si c'est vrai mais bon
puisque 20 mai deux ça tu l'a prouvé
quoi non faut pas qu'ils ne doivent pas
abuser d'accord bob mongrain allez mange
en lui soyez gentil à la jean michel
maire qui revenue tient un peu doucement
pour benoît
allez allez vous aujourd'hui au ces
cette question qu'à terre on les attend
ce seront les derniers quatre tiers de
l'année et soyez gentil après on
découvrira le père noël mystère qui est
le père noël mystère à aller tout de
suite de la question allez c'est parti
gentil bonjour je m'appelle and l'année
dernière je trouvais le connais car de
plus en plus quand en septembre pour
améliorer les choses vous avez recruté
delormeau et moulay donc j'aurai une
seule question nous vous vient cet
humour
monsanto non j'aime bien les deux
nouveaux ouais c'est pas de l'humour
sharan l'émission s'est vraiment
améliorée avec les nouveaux chroniqueurs
elle a surtout gagné en flagornerie pour
cyril mais il faut le reconnaître
l'arrivée de mathieu a fait beaucoup de
bien dans ce domaine c'est que l'amour
c'est la dévotion et pour satisfaire son
sont tunisiens aux yeux de velours
mathieu est prêt à tout vraiment à tous
et brief même les nouveaux regarder
oui
à
à mon bébé c'est comme ça des heures et
des heures vote toujours en faire trop à
occuper mais c'est un tchèque tchèque
mais a oui allez non ces messieurs jean
luc il est beau comme ça et dire un
arbitre de billard excusez moi mais ya
que moi qui va prendre ce soir nous
avais tu crois quoi elle a gagné son
père me jean-luc je lui avais tout cas
on n'a rien à dire un poulpe c'est à les
mojawi c'est la région mathieu c'est
important de parler arabe si on veut
rester mix il ne comprend pas battu
erika donc font partie des nouveaux et
coup de bol ils s'adorent on voit ici 16
ans on les croyait en froid mais en fait
bien du tout mathieu et foot son
ex-collègue d'nrj12 regardez bien son
petit sourire satisfait à la fin
je viens
je
il est content avec ça va mieux ça mc
doom et voilà c'est bien bon bon chemin
mieux bien sûr un abri content il a
balancé sa petite vacherie et vous allez
voir que ça fait beaucoup mieux dans
l'extrait suivant
c'est comme si les joueurs il a stone
sour mathieu à côté de qui eric america
évidemment
je ne parle pas de parler en proposent
sur le bateau
on va regarder
messieurs capricieux
c'est vraiment
richard erika vous savez moi j'ai mal au
coeur moi je vous aime fort vous le
savez heureusement que vous êtes tous
les chroniqueurs d'ailleurs fort vous le
savez il n'ya pas franchement y'a pas de
favoritisme ont flingué mais c'est vrai
il n'ya pas de favoritisme
éric allain là là franchement dallas il
a été dur koné saydoo
c'était avant parce que j'étais au samu
ou non cette semaine tu m'as dit la même
chose non non pas l'animosité entre les
candidats d'accord je me suis demandé
pourquoi y avait tout ça pour quoi que
comment se fait-il que mathieu soit si
mal acceptée par ses camarades
et franchement je comprenais pas mais
heureusement le beau matthew lui même
est venu nous expliquer attention
boulard en approche
puis la mère mathieu anthony oui c'est
vrai le mien tu es content qu'il reste
alors dans touche pas à mon poste
ben je voulais pas qu'ils partent bon
ballon pour nrj12 ouais c'est vrai coup
de filet au bar depuis deux ans original
attendez je vais très bien dire une job
de truc à moi mon chéri non ça va très
bien pu me dit où boîtier tu me donnes
tout ce que tu veux donc il rend jaloux
beaucoup de monde mathieu on sait pas
qui m'aimait beaucoup c'est pour ça que
siri le protège et s'inquiète des qui
quitte le plateau regarder des moutons
encore tout n'est pas important
j'ai triché a seulement connu il ya des
trucs
il ya un truc un peu bizarre acteurs de
jean-michel alors alors on mettra
surtout les yeux lance aucune n'est pas
un portique c'est bien le rappeler en
parlant de siri vous vous savez qu'il
aime beaucoup les chansons de patrick
sébastien et bien c'est étonnant mais de
temps en temps il a des moments de
lucidité que cette mère qui passe le
plus vite du monde du mode kif au mode
vénère bon c'est bon c'est bon
à bien des conneries juillet pendrel
chaque soir on nous a mis là il y en a
pas mais on nous a mis sur les deux
étapes des petites paillettes très
collante très chiante clé qui servent à
rien à part faire une petite déco bien
kitsch comme les sapins un jeu
magnifique bienvenue au 20e siècle
en tout cas des paillettes très collant
des chroniqueurs en gros tout ce qu'il
fallait pour que cyril nous met en
angoisse et lance à nouveau un deux
trois races rats
janvier à bata moi qui doivent être
passés baugur attentionné l'accord
j'ai pensé avec mes copains telle chance
ici le chant du cygne
et les fiers de lui
il est comme ça cyril un sale gosse mais
quel sens des affaires c'est bientôt
noël et comme chaque année cyril a
décidé de sortir des produits dérivés
touche pas à mon poste sans nous en
parler
cette année le produit phare le range
stylo isabelle morini-bosc toujours
des gens dans sa tête qui habitent les
séjours quand ils salle où ces cas lucho
tendance police a aussi prouvé un tempo
s'est pas fait ça pour nous mais ça va
vous sinon il sera chez vous avez gagné
le permis c'est vrai je voulais tu donc
j'ai le droit de faire des écarts de
conduite mais l'âge des personnes qui
personne qui comprenne mieux monde
isabelle que ses filles et se sont pas
de berlin ce sont des jumelles d'envoi
la légende des bleus mort à bercy allez
on y va quand même bizarre j'ai même
beaucoup mais elle est bizarre
vous savez quand isabelle n'arrive pas à
prendre la parole et finit par parler un
petit dialecte africain a connu
rappelez vous l'année dernière
un des deux en langage pygmées ça veut
dire je suis d'accord elle a remis ça
cette année
ben voilà comment on dit dans son
langage je vous prie de m'excuser petit
homme au corps pour lui mais il me
semble que vous avez oublié de me donner
la parole geoffrey dont tu parles qui
est ici ou est un des garçons les plus
intelligents que je connais dans la télé
règles oui c'est bizarre ce soir-là d'or
souhaite parler notre langue soit la
rive sur le plateau complètement bourré
et il faut le reconnaître elle n'est pas
la seule donc je n'ai pas pu résister au
plaisir de ralentir quelques images pour
justifier l'état de mes camarades car
vous allez voir au ralenti ils ont
vraiment l'air torché
n'est pas d'accord isabelle poudroux
excessif parce que honnêtement il a des
qualités lesquels lesquels il ya pleins
effets de scène des décors magiques
magistraux le chasseur se distend la
faute 6 fois
jean-michel m6 évidemment mais bon des
bouts je suis ni van toi t'es pas
vivante et me maurer
je ne suis pas votre punch bowl
chérimont donner un truc quoi votre vie
et essayer de respirer enfin je rappelle
qu'avec la plupart du pays
d'autres pays sont pus débloquerez
douvres en plus d'habitants dans faut
mieux nombre d'étrangers que d'acheter
les horse j'ai rien à offrir
vous n'êtes pas fait le pire truc qui
est de l'eau salée
la nature est brouillonne l'émission
marche en dominant mieux nous recevons
de plus en plus de stars pour le plus
grand bonheur des capteurs
un merci à toutes les stars devenir bien
évidemment notamment le jour de la venue
lara fabian
areva et n'aura été comme une folle
ça
à
est mort
hélas
tu peux fermer ta gueule
touche pas à mon poste allait elle était
bien sur le coup le journal du textile
voilà un peu moins sur le coup 1 en même
temps c'est tellement classe et de
mettre un gros vent une star
internationale
voici le serge lama du mois non
we give it to me bébé ou la vache quand
même ya vachement moubarak
attendez avant avant ça je vais demander
à castres kaka du public vont reprendre
le chemin grave entre temps heureusement
les autres médicaments que tu
connaissais si le mot chéri e non
d'accord merci mais non mais non
régis aller dormir aller dormir et
dormir il est tard merci des chiens mais
heureusement les autres chroniqueurs ont
fait honneur à des missions ou pas mais
regardez moi c'est lourdingue
pendant la pause pub ils vont tous venir
semer le pauvre s'ils n'ont en même
temps c'est ce qu'ils font pour tous les
invités
je veux bien aussi
moi je ne sais pas alors je vais faire
c'est vrai
moi j'aime autant les deux fabrice éboué
que j'adore depuis peu quand même
bah oui moi je mange des bonbons
fabrique c'est pas recevoir les gens
c'est pas ma faute envers les stars qui
font plaisir on recevait il ya peu
sophie favier
ah oui qui venaient nous parler de son
régime surtout de vous vous devez perdre
15 kilos en trois mois
ça avance bien oui j'ai déjà perdu 10
kilos
non mais quel beau c'est pas possible à
20 à le dire du mal des gens quand ils
sont pas en plateau
ah oui c'est amusant alors que si je
passais ta tête qu'en syrie des
étudiants de mokhtar par exemple un tu
serais mal bon t'as le temps du magnéto
pour partir en courant mokhtar vrai
qu'il a un succès incroyable nos
chansons et potard et à chaque fois les
fans me disent qu'est-ce qu'il est beau
ce motard non mais sert et on m'a dit
les sexy les baux est encore plus beau
en vrai c'est encore quelques autres
mais bon ça va se régler après match en
prime ça je pense disons le tout net
jean michel est une grande gueule
le vendredi se retrouvent souvent
entouré de filles dans l'émission de
julien courbet il aime bien ça hein ça
lui permet de faire le match au camp des
collègues parlent voici sa meilleure
intervention lors de la dernière
émission c'est plus une transformation
du patro enlever sa vision de sa société
que juste un mécanisme de perruques et
de visites mais non c'était important de
gagner et tout ça joue mercy bay la
carotte le vendredi jean-michel est en
roue libre à m'aimer mais vraiment parce
que quand il dit pash 8 voilà voilà ce
qui fait pendant les pubs au milieu des
filles temps on va le calmer jules si si
des enfants sont encore devant la télé
allez des couches et tout ça alors
attention
anthony alors tony van der sar
20minutes quoi on est content c'est bien
pour notre de broussailles c'est bon
quand je l'aï punch et bien sûr tout le
tour pas que ça fasse a du poids ok je
vous dis la vérité et monter des blancs
des jaunes pareil vu son expérience du
poignet on aurait pu croire que ça
serait facile pour lui il va pas tant
que ça comme les politiques et
honnêtement un autre public
c'est bon mais pas dur comme la ville de
dà comme la vie de céline
le mec il vénère avait jadis ya beaucoup
de talent mais on savait pas c'est qu'il
était imitateur ce que vous savez qui
l'imité johnny hallyday dans les dents
les aura aidé des chroniqueurs dont qui
l'a pas fait j'ai dit jeudi pas vous
allez voir c'est comme ça que jean
michel voit johnny hallyday
oui c'est très personnel
moi je sais pas que johnny sensibilité
comme ça mais bon ce qui ce qui est bien
c'est qu'avec les nouveaux chroniqueurs
je peux utiliser deux fois les plus les
off
là on va repasser les mêmes images mais
on va s'intéresser maintenant à nos amis
mathieu erika a regardé matin n'en peux
plus je n'en peux plus de voir l'autre
s'agiter à côté de lui donc il va
d'abord essayer des petits coups comme
ça puis des regards exaspéré pour
finalement agir non
on va regarder
exactement médical mais là je me suis
tout de suite exécuté mais il est aussi
des fois là non je crois que s'ils
pouvaient il a tu as vu du tout
inquiétez pas on est là on faisait avant
c'était avant ça c'était au moins yaya
diane bien c'était dans la semaine on
attend des réflexions inattendu et
franchement ça fait mon bonheur las je
pense que c'est ma vidéo préfet du mois
entier bâle a regardé niveau premier
degré c'est fabuleux
angoulême angoulême deux minutes d'arrêt
veuillez vous éloigner de la bordure uk
le train desservira les gares de mouches
ville
pyros a également bordeaux mérignac a
tout de suite avec bien sûr des mélèzes
à 15 euros 50
oui
et si et si
voilà donc passer par angoulême 3
minutes sans même que n'arrive
c'est vrai on prendra le temps un jour
ça vous d'abord puis là si je vous jure
3 pour moi alors voila merci mes traites
a très bien sauté cbg danse et oubliez
pas que lui qui peut sentir ça en vrac
maintenant est ce que vous voulez savoir
ce que fait valérie bénaïm comme ça et
en publicité
oui bah je sais pas je sais pas mais par
contre je peux vous montrer ce que
benhaim fait quand elle croit être en
publicité alors que pas du tout c'était
juste un jingle
on va les jambes et 1
salle en 2016 aura plus de portable sur
la table non ah si je voulais dire à
plus de portable sur un talon du
connected je n'y aura plus de départ du
chef à la fao médias car ils vont nous
en direct pour réagir pour vous d'infos
médias carré de l'ajc par régis sur le
plateau vous réagissiez déjà assez il
n'y aura plus de portable sur le plateau
à la rentrée 2007 je vous le dis même
celui non moi c'est pas pareil parce que
forcément j'ai des chiffres qui tombent
tous les quarts d'heure était sa maman
maman chez texto thierry brault fabas
temps vous pourrez plus loin d'envoyer
puis sur l'île de ré alors le 1er
décembre dernier pour la sortie de mon
dvd cyril avait présenté un de mes
précédents spectacles
ah oui pour me faire une farce et à
l'intérieur il avait glissé une surprise
l'occasion rêvée pour thierry moreau de
faire une blague regardez sa vitesse de
réaction
il ya douze ans que je les faits se
seraient tous en suis là mais à waimes
et parce que j'ai tous vos dvd à la
maison mais faudrait les ouvrir même oui
je laissais l'âge est là je me suis
trompé je sais c'est pas
dans un lieu s'est trouvée servir
vivacité d'esprit qui force le respect
en tout cas et comme cette année tiré eu
la chance de recevoir l'award de la
meilleure blague télé ah oui je vais
l'aider pour l'année prochaine ainsi
écrit le savoir de la blague
le français a alors vous quand même
terrible mais ça va bien de la rizière
plus tôt
hello après les dramatiques événements
de novembre
la reprise avait été très compliqué on
savait pas comment faire pour trouver le
bon ton le ton juste car l'ambiance
était lourde rapporte pour tout le monde
heureusement cyril a pris ses
responsabilités parce qu'elle allait
s'en est bien sorti elle est sans pitié
nos rares et elle assume sa vie donc
trente secondes plus tard elle a été
voir le principal concerné aujourd'hui
c'est l'arrivée nous ou les petites à
danané 4/3 c'est sa cour on aime bien
vous êtes bien comme ça et noir était le
fils you come on américains sont mêlés
matures comme elle est restée comme ça
mais c'est vrai que ces nations ont dit
non mais surtout qu'en plus c'est très
important de flatter le patron et
n'était pas la seule parce que si on ne
pense pas je vibrais sur et enora il y
en a plein d'autres
regardez d'ailleurs la preuve avec un
nouveau numéro du palmarès à face à des
chroniqueurs les plus fayot avec cyril
hanouna elle fait une entrée timide mais
elle va vite se mettre au diapason
estelle denis
est ce que vous êtes devenu hanouna
addict
d'une certaine manière à moi que je suis
hanouna admirative
c'est surtout quelqu'un a déjà des idées
tout le temps je vous parlais d'aisance
et de marque ressuscitée
s'il a créé combien de marque sur des
beats est absolument incroyable
il ne contredit jamais cyril hanouna qui
a déjà changé sorbet x 52 x
il est d'accord sur tout même quand il
ne comprend pas bertrand chamerois
je sais c'est un peu une secte mmp donc
ses gloires à ses rides mais c'est
mérité parce que vraiment cyril je pense
qu'il s'est un petit peu la pièce qui
manquait au paf
ils aiment tellement lécher le derrière
de cirque à la place de sa langue
il s'est fait greffer un gant de
toilette jean michel maire
la roulette
franchement je serais le plus malheureux
des hommes si je travaillais pas ici
paraît pas changé ma vie
changé ma vie il fait une entrée
fracassante dans ce classement à l'école
c'est les mecs qui apporterait des
gâteaux la maîtresse matthieu delormeau
c'est une goutte pour les
téléspectateurs encore une fois vous
quel un grand que certainement le plus
grand de nous sauf
même si ta parole pour moi c'est
étonnant della bella c'est quoi ça merci
thierry moreau je trouve ça très large
parce qu'évidemment ils ont pris la
fonction écrit me lèche je me suis dit
ah quand même
la lune est à l'union et au nord-ouest
il a battu parlons pas trop où on casse
a battu la creuse personne ne s'en
méfier elle est fourbe et forte à la
fois elle prend directement la première
place valérie benaïm d'abord c'est mon
ami vraiment dans la vie on s'est
vraiment mon passé mon petit frère mon
grand frère selon les circonstances
c'est un tel que j'admire
professionnellement parce que voilà je
vous disais c'est quelqu'un qui qui ne
s'endort pas
moi j'adore j'adore j'adore aussi cette
success story de cyril que personne n'a
vu arriver cyril hanouna on le prenait
pour un pigeon finalement c'est un
condor donc voilà
non
elle n'est pas là monsieur nature à
marbella et mon amour bon barman et
laisser son admiration à la
ça fait combien de temps qu'on est
ensemble maintenant ça fait un petit
bout de vingt ans ce qui trahit jamais
jamais jamais jamais on est comme ça
c'est comme ça pas encore comme ça on
n'est pas encore à briquet et tu es mal
non plus qu'est-ce qu'ils pas non plus
jamais jamais jamais jamais - aubergines
farcies
aujourd'hui c'est fini c'est fini